père de julian assange devant
l'assemblée nationale à paris
aujourd'hui il a rencontré plusieurs
députés des élus qui appelle d'ailleurs
la france a accordé l'asile aux lanceurs
d'alert actuellement emprisonné au
royaume uni ils ont présenté leur
résolution les précisions de notre
reporter marième l'arrivée de jean-luc
mélenchon à jean lassalle en passant par
cédric villani jean christophe lagarde
ou françois ruffin ils sont une
quarantaine de députés français à porter
ou à soutenir ce projet de résolution au
titre de l'article 34 1 de la
constitution pour accorder l'asile à
julian assange le journaliste et
fondateur de wikileaks est détenu depuis
deux ans et demi dans une prison de
haute sécurité à londres après avoir
passé sept ans confiné et réfugié dans
l'ambassade d'équateur pour les députés
français le second crime de julian
assange et d'avoir révélé la vérité sur
les guerres américaines au moyen-orient
mais pour eux également la france a une
dette envers julian assange on les
écoute je le crois qu'il ya une prise de
conscience sur l'importance des
documents qui ont été révélés au monde
entier par julian assange
de l'influent si l'anti sur la marche
des affaires du monde et enfin et
peut-être
sur l'espère la face voudra rappeler
qu'elle a une voix universaliste et une
voix qui peut s'élever au dessus d un
sourd sur de l'histoire il ya la liberté
ne pays quelque part qui se trouvait
être espionnés par son allié américain
sous trois présidents successifs jacques
chirac nicolas sarkozy françois hollande
révélée par julian assange services
rendus à la nation et donc oui je pense
que là il ya des motifs qui sont des
motifs différents qui peuvent se meut
les se mêler ces cumuls et qui font que
des parlementaires venant de tous
horizons différentes did on doit lui
accorder le droit d'asile julian assange
doit pouvoir sortir de sa prison
anglaise échapper aux griffes américaine
et venir dans l'esprit de voltaire de se
réfugier dans le pays cette conférence
de presse qui s'est tenue en présence du
père de julian assange john shipton
ainsi que de sa compagne estelle à
maurice qui tous les deux ont exprimé un
grand espoir devant cette initiative des
parlementaires français on écoute le
père de julian assange
on assiste ici à la naissance d'un
mouvement en france il y a 6 parlement
dans le monde qui ont composé des
groupes trans partisan pour assange
c'est le cas au bundestag votre voisin
ici en france la france bien sûr le
royaume uni la grèce en main et l'italie
en un l'espagne aussi et enfin
l'australie en un il ya donc un
mouvement à travers le monde qui se
constituent pour que justice pour que
julian puisse rentrer à la maison ce
n'est pas grand chose juste qu'il puisse
rentrer à la maison
d'ici la mi-décembre la justice
britannique doit rendre son verdict sur
l'appel des etats-unis contre le refus
d'extradition de julian assange mais
quel que soit ce verdict la partie
perdante pourra toujours faire appel
devant la cour suprême du royaume uni ce
qui prolongera la détention de julian
assange son père et sa compagne dénonce
ses conditions de détention et alertes
sur son état de santé physique et
psychologique qui selon eux empire de
semaine en semaine